The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So last time we were
starting more complicated
mechanisms and we looked
at series reactions.
A goes B, which is
an intermediate.
Goes to C with rates
k1 and k2.
And we solved the
problem exactly.
Which turned out to be a
little bit complicated.
And then we were looking
at special cases.
And I left the special case
of k1 equals k2 to do as a
homework problem.
And then on the board we did
k1 much greater than k2.
Which looks like, if k1 is much
greater than k2, the rate
into k1 is much greater than
k2, so using the analogy of
buckets and pipes, it's a big
pipe between k1 and between A
and B. And a little pipe
between B and C and you
started with a bunch
of liquid on top.
And you basically dump
it into here.
And then you slowly
drip into C here.
So the first thing that happens
is that A gets dumped,
it becomes B very quickly.
With a rate constant k1.
In a first order fashion.
So A is A0 e to the minus
k1 times time.
Then B comes up sharply.
And then drops down with rate
constant k2 slowly.
So B is approximately A0 e to
the minus k2 times time.
And then C has a very small
quadratic rise, followed by
the exponential rise to
saturation that you'd expect.
So C is approximately a0 times
one minus e to the minus k2
times time.
The rate constant k2 dominates
the long times.
And everything it's looking like
it's pseudo first order
at long times.
So you can do this either by
thinking about it, solve the
problem by thinking about it,
which is perfectly fine.
Or you can do it by solving
it exactly, as we
have done last time.
And then putting in the
right approximations.
Which in this case was Taylor's
approximation, if I
remember right.
And know just by looking at the
equation and putting the
right approximation,
you get it out.
And a third approximation, which
is the opposite one, k2
much less than k1, so k1 much
less than k2, the way that
that's going to look, we can
do it by inspection.
So basically if we think of
buckets and pipes, that's a
very thin pipe connecting the
bucket for A and B, so we drip
from A to B, then we have this
very fat pipe connecting B and
C. So as soon as a little B gets
in there, it immediately
becomes C. So, the rate
determining step is the first
one, A goes to B. And so k1, we
expect that to be the rate
that dominates the long time.
And we never expect to get any
significant amount of B to
pile up in the middle bucket,
because this pipe is much
bigger than that one here.
Therefore, what we expect to see
is a slow decay in A, with
rate constant k1 dominating
the long times, A is
approximately A0 e to the
minus k1 times the time.
We don't expect B to amount
to very much at all.
It'll rise up a little bit at
the very early times, and
it'll pretty much stay
very, very small.
Not quite constant.
And in fact if you look at the
full result, and you put in
your approximations, and I'll
let you do that, you would
find that B is essentially
related to A through a
constant term where k1 is very
small compared to k2.
So this is a very small
number here.
B is equal to a very small
number times A. So it
basically follows A, but at
a very very, low level.
And then you would find that C
rises up in approximately e to
the minus k1 times t, so
with rate constant k1.
One minus e to the minus
k1 times the time.
So the dominant rate is k1, and
in this case here this is
an approximation that we're
going to see again.
We're going to revisit this
approximation here when we get
to more complicated mechanisms,
it's going to
become this steady state
approximation.
Where the amount of the
intermediate, or the
concentration of intermediate,
is low at all times.
And doesn't change very fast.
The slope here is very slow.
Because k1 is so slow coming
down, and B is related to A,
which means it's related to this
slow decrease in A, the
amount of B is small and the
rate of change in B is also
very small.
And hopefully we'll
get to that very
soon in this lecture.
OK, so that's a summary of
what we did last time.
Any questions?
So the next thing now is to
go to the next mechanism.
Which is, so far we've looked
at reactions that
proceed all the way.
We haven't looked at
equilibrium yet.
But we know thermodynamics
is all about equilibrium.
So now we're going to connect
kinetics and thermodynamics.
We're going to look at a
mechanism which is an
equilibrium mechanism.
Equilibrium or reversible
reactions.
Where you have A goes to B, with
summary constant k1, but
you can have the reverse process
B goes back to A with
the rate constant k minus one.
Or you can write is as A k1, k
minus one to B, where k1 could
be k forward and k minus one
could be k backwards.
Also written as k sub
f, and this is also
written as k sub b.
So now we have more
information than we had before.
Because now we know this is
an equilibrium problem.
And we already know about
equilibrium from
thermodynamics.
And we know that at equilibrium,
in addition to
all the rate laws that we're
going to write down to solve
the problem, we also know
that at equilibrium, the
equilibrium constant is related
to the equilibrium
concentrations.
To the ratio of the equilibrium
This is something additional
that we have.
So let's write down everything
we know.
And our goal is to find
out the time, the
dynamics of this problem.
Suppose you start at some time
t equals zero, at a certain
amount of A0 in your pot, a
certain amount of B0, how do
you get to equilibrium.
What's the rate, what
does it look like?
So the first thing is to
write down the rates.
So the forward rate minus dA/dt,
which is the forward
rate, R sub forward is equal
to k1 times A. And the
backwards rate, minus dB/dt,
which we can write as R sub
backwards, that's k minus one
times B. At equilibrium, we
have no dynamics.
Or no ensemble dynamics.
The pot looks constant.
It doesn't look like anything's
going on in there.
The concentration of
A doesn't change.
B doesn't change.
They're constant at the
equilibrium concentration.
So that implies that the rate
of formation of B must be
equal to the rate of destruction
of B. Or, in other
words, that the rate forward at
equilibrium has to be equal
the rate backwards.
Otherwise, there'd be changes
in concentrations.
So if that's true, then that
means that at equilibrium, k1
A equilibrium has to be equal to
k minus one B equilibrium.
Which means that we can get this
ratio of B to A. And see
that this is equal to
k1 over k minus one.
So we've just, this is
pretty major here.
Looks pretty simple,
but we've taken an
equilibrium property here.
And related to kinetics.
To a rate property.
So here we have kinetics.
Here we have thermo.
And this is going to turn out
to be, this kind of ratio
between forward rates and
backwards rates, related to
equilibrium constants is going
to be valid, not just for this
very simple mechanism we have
here with just two species.
But it's going to be valid
for more complicated.
And we have two species reacting
to form another
species, or bimolecular
stuff, et cetera.
OK, so now we've laid
the groundwork,
let's look at the dynamics.
Let's look at the
time evolution.
So that means that we need
to take, well this
is not quite right.
I shouldn't write minus dA/dt.
This is minus dA/dt rate forward
in the absence of
reverse process.
It says just the destruction of
A and not the creation of
A. So if you look at the full
kinetics, the full mechanism,
this also, the rate backwards is
minus dB/dt, in the absence
of forming B back through
the reverse process.
So both of these are
in the absence of
their reverse process.
The full kinetics, for the
destruction of A. A is the
rate backwards, or the rate
forwards, which is k1 times A,
and then the rate backwards,
which is the creation of A.
That's the two rates together.
Minus k minus one times B.
There's the formation of A
here, this is the destruction
of A. This is the full
differential equation for
the full mechanism.
Not just one part of it.
This one here is just for the
first step, and that one here
is for the second step.
This is what we need to solve.
But now we have a lot of help
by what we've already done.
So, what we can do is well, the
problem here is that's it
looks hard because there's
B included in here.
This is not just A,
there's B in here.
But there's only two species.
And stoichiometry is going
to help us out.
Remember last time, or a few
times ago, we said the last
species is the easy one.
Because it's always related to
the concentration of all the
other species by
stoichiometry.
And the last one here is B. So
we know that B is related to
A. B is whatever you
started out with.
Plus whatever you used
up for A. That's one
way of writing it.
So you start with this amount,
and you create this amount.
By having A react.
This is what you started with,
A, and this is what's left.
The difference has to go into
B. So stroke stoichiometry
give you a relationship, which
you can use to plug into your
differential equation here.
And now, after rearranging your
differential equation,
putting B in there, you can
rewrite this as k1 plus k
minus one times A minus k minus
one times B0 plus A0.
Something which depends
on A, something
which is constant here.
OK, and what else do we know?
We know something about
equilibrium.
We know something about when
we reach a state where the
rate forward is equal to
the rate backward.
When the rate forward is equal
to the rate backwards, the
rate of change of A is zero.
A is not changing.
The concentration of
So at equilibrium, dA/dt
is equal to zero.
And just like in this example
here, this is going to turn
out to be related to an
approximation called the
steady state approximation,
which we're going to see later
this morning.
Writing at equilibrium that
the change in the
concentration of one of the
species is equal to zero,
we're going to use that as an
approximation also later, when
we get to more complicated
mechanisms.
This is going to be the
equilibrium approximation.
And this is going to be the
steady state approximation.
Let's keep going with our, we're
solving this guy here.
So at equilibrium, dA/dt
is equal to zero.
And then we can replace our
concentrations here with, and
so if you write equal to zero
here, then we can write it as
equilibrium right here.
And we'll be able to solve for
A equilibrium in terms of k1,
k minus one, B0, and A0.
And then if you do that, you get
A equilibrium is equal to
k minus one over k1 plus k minus
one times B0 plus A0.
And we're going to need that.
Because now we're going to be
able to plug this, so there's
A0 plus B0 sitting here.
And we're going to replace
A0 plus B0 in terms of A
equilibrium.
There's a minus sign here.
And between this A and this
A equilibrium here, so by
rewriting, by plugging in A B0
A equilibrium instead of B0
plus A0, we can rewrite that
equation as dA/dt is equal to
k1 plus k minus one times
A minus A equilibrium.
This is nice because, this
quantity, A minus A
equilibrium, describes the
difference between where are
you are and where
you want to be.
It's a nice variable to have.
It's going to change in time and
at infinite time, this is
going to go to zero.
A is going to go
to equilibrium.
A equilibrium is a constant.
Now we have a differential
equation that relates A to
this difference.
But A equilibrium
is a constant.
So there's nothing that forbids
us from just writing
minus A equilibrium here. d
of a constant dt is zero.
So I'm just basically
subtracting zero here.
So and I have something of the
form dx/dt is equal to
constant times x.
And I know how to write that.
That looks just like a
first order process.
I know the solution is A minus
A equilibrium is equal to my
initial A, my initial state.
A0 times e to the minus k1 plus
k minus one times time.
And I've solved the problem.
I've described how, as a
function of time, how A, the
concentration of A,
gets equilibrium.
And if you want to know B,
it's just the same thing.
You replace B here
and B0 here.
You put k minus one here, k1
here, but it's the same thing.
So if you were to sketch it
out as a function of time,
there's, eventually you'll get
to the concentration A
equilibrium.
If you're above it, you're
going to decay in a first
order fashion, with a
rate constant k1.
A minus A equilibrium is A0
minus A equilibrium e to the
minus k prime times t, where k
prime is k1 plus k minus one.
And this is when A is greater
than A0, A equilibrium.
A0 is greater than
equilibrium.
And if you start below, you're
going to come up like this.
A0 is less than A equilibrium.
And both rates come into here,
in a very simple way.
Just the sum of the two.
So experimental, if you want to
find out these rates, you
can measure their equilibrium
concentrations.
Measure k equilibrium by
obtaining the equilibrium
concentrations of B and A. And
that gives you the ratio of k1
plus k minus one.
And then you can just start
the process with some
concentration of A. Which is
different in equilibrium.
Then watching it in time,
extract out, observe and
measure k1 plus k minus one.
In this kinetic equation.
At kinetic relation.
And then you have two results,
two pieces of data.
You've measured k prime, which
gives you the sum of the two.
And you've measured K
equilibrium, which gives you
the ratio of the two.
And you've got your two
rate constants out.
OK, any questions for the
equilibrium problem?
We're slowly -- yes.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: There is not yet
a relationship between
k1 and k minus one.
It depends on the problem.
And we're going to study the,
when we get to potential
barriers, we look at, we'll
look at this issue.
OK, it's a good question.
We're going to do that
probably next time.
So let's get going, then, with
reversible reactions.
So now we have, let's make it a
little bit more complicated.
Let's, instead of two species,
let's make it three species.
So we have A plus B goes to C,
where the rate constant k1,
and then C goes to A plus to B
with a rate constant k minus
one that you can rewrite as A
plus B goes to C, k1, k minus
one, and then you write down
your, you want to solve this.
So the first thing you do
is your write down your
differential equations. dA/dt is
equal to, put all the rates
in there. k1 A B minus k minus
one times C. And at
equilibrium, we set that
equal to zero.
So you can write equilibrium
here, equilibrium here,
equilibrium here.
And when you bring this term
over to the other side, you
find, then that at equilibrium
the ratio of the forward rate
to the backward rates is equal
to C equilibrium divided by A
equilibrium.
The equilibrium, which,
you know is
the equilibrium constant.
So again, for this slightly more
complicated problem, the
ratio of the forward and
backward rates are related to
the equilibrium constant.
So now you want to solve this.
Well, we're not even
going to try.
Because it's going to
be too complicated.
So as soon as you get away from
first order kinetics and
go to second order kinetics
with multiple
steps, it's a mess.
So instead you try to
find approximations.
In this case here there's
one we can use.
Or a limiting case, at least.
One we can use, which
is an obvious
one, which is flooding.
As a limiting case.
If we want to isolate a small
part of the problem, we can
use flooding.
Because we can overwhelm the
system with either A or B.
Take B0 much greater
than A0 and C0.
So over the course of the
reaction of the process, the
concentration of B
hardly changes.
And so when we write our kinetic
equation, our rate
law, k1 A B minus k minus one
C, we could put a little
naught here, because
we know the
concentration of B is not changing.
And so now we're left with the
problem we had before.
Which was a reversible first
order process which we have
just solved.
And you go through the
experiment and you extract out
k1 times B0 and k minus one.
You do the experiment again with
a different concentration
of B0 to start out with.
And you can extract out k1.
So this is a process of getting
the rates by using a
simple approximation here.
Simple limiting case.
Any questions?
So we've just finished putting
all the building blocks
together now.
Let me remind you what these
building blocks are.
We have a bunch of
approximations under our belt.
Flooding, we've looked
at rates being
much faster than others.
And we have three simple
mechanisms, we've looked at
parallel reactions.
We looked at series reactions.
And we've looked at reversible
reactions.
So a complicated mechanism will
basically put these three
building blocks together
in a series.
And they'll all be happening
at the same time somehow.
And obviously, since it was,
since we threw up our hands,
just with a simple reversible
process like here, it's clear
that we're going to throw
up our hands a lot.
When we write down
these mechanisms.
So we're going to need
approximations.
We're going to need something
that we'll automatically go
to, and say this is going
to be too hard.
I'm not even going to try.
Let's do an approximation.
And two approximations that
we're going to talk about are
ones I already mentioned
at the beginning.
Which is the steady state
approximation, where one rate,
the rate to go into the
intermediate is very slow, or
the rate to get out of the
intermediate is very fast.
And the equilibrium
approximation where the system
sets up a very fast equilibrium
and you're allowed
to use thermodynamics
to help you out
in solving the problem.
These are the two approximations
that we'll use
when we put these
things together.
OK, so let's look at the
first, simple, more
complicated mechanism.
To see where these
approximations come in.
So the first one is going
to be a series.
We're going to start putting
these things together.
First one is a series
reversible.
Those two together.
Series reversible.
So we have first, a reversible
process.
Everything is first order here.
k minus one goes to B.
And then B goes to C with
some rate constant
k2, all first order.
If we were to turn the crank,
we'd say, oh, I've got to
write down all my
rate laws here.
Minus dA/dt is all the ways that
I destroy and create B,
so there's a k1 times A minus
k minus one times B. dB/dt,
all the ways that create and
destroy B is that you create
it through destruction of A.
I destroy it through the
backwards rate to make A. And
I destroy it by making the
product, C. There's
the intermediate.
And then for C, that's
pretty simple.
There's only one channel into C,
and that's the destruction
of B to form C, k2 B.
All the rate laws.
I write everything
I know here.
Couple of differential
equations.
We know it's going to
be hard to solve.
So, let's remind ourselves
of what I just erased.
Which was the case where the
intermediate concentration was
always very small and didn't
change very fast.
And the process was dominated
by k1 here.
That was the rate
limiting step.
Remember that our first
example this morning.
So this is where the
concentration of B is roughly
constant over time.
It's small.
And over any small time period,
it's roughly constant.
Which means that dB/dt is
roughly equal to zero.
If you look at a long term,
obviously it's going to change
as you go from this point
to that point.
In fact, there's a relationship
between A which
is changing in time and B. But
A is also changing in time
very slowly.
Because the rate k1
is very small.
So dB/dt, which is related to
this rate k1, is going to be
very slowly changing in time.
We can approximate it at zero.
What are the ways in terms of
matching these rate constants
that we can get to the
approximation.
To a diagram that
looks like that?
But we don't want
B to pile up.
That means we have to have the
rates out of the intermediate
to be much faster, at least one
of the rates out of the
intermediate to be much faster
than the rate that creates the
intermediate.
So the different ways of
creating that approximation
are if, and the length of the
arrows now is going to be
proportional to the rate.
We want it to be very hard to
make B. And as soon as we make
B, we want it to go away.
So one of the ways to do that
is to have the reverse rate
much faster than the
initial rate.
And we could have a slow rate
into C, that's fine.
We could have, again, a very
slow rate into B. We could
have a slow reverse rate
and a fast rate into
C. Perfectly fine.
We could have both.
Fast rate out of B through A, or
out of B through C. As long
as this first rate into the B
is small compared to one of
those two rates, we're never
going to pile up B. It's going
to go away as soon
as we make it.
So in all these cases, k2
plus k minus one is
much bigger than k1.
When we have that situation,
then we can make the
approximation up here.
That the rate of change
in B is very small.
Almost zero, which means it's
basically a constant.
And instead of writing B in this
case here, we're going to
write it as B steady state.
Which is basically a constant
in terms of solving the
differential equations.
And that's going to make
our life much easier.
Because instead of having
to solve these coupled
differential equations, we're
just going to have to solve
coupled algebraic equations.
Which is really messy,
but less hard.
If you're a bean-counter
than this is heaven.
So now we're going to put steady
state, this is going to
be a constant.
And this is going to
be equal to zero.
And then here this is going
to be steady state here.
This is going to be
steady state here.
And the first thing to do now is
that we've eliminated this
differential equation.
We now have an algebraic
equation where we can solve
for B steady state.
So if you recognize that you're
in this situation here,
forget about trying to solve.
Immediately go to the process
of putting in a constant for
B. Setting dB/dt for the
intermediate equal to zero.
And then starting to turn the
crank on the algebra.
So let me go ahead and
turn the crank here.
Go through the steps,
which is basically
typical of these problems.
So you turn the crank.
You solve for the steady
state concentration.
You get, in terms of A, over
k minus one, plus k2.
Then you plug this
back in here.
And you get a new differential
equation, minus dA/dt is equal
to k1 times A minus k minus one
times B steady state, so
we plug this in here.
And you get, so there's
A sitting here.
It's going to be of the form,
effective rate times A. It's
going to be basically
a first order form.
Which is what we'd expect
from sketching the
diagram just like that.
So you get minus dA/dt is an
effective rate. k1 times k2
over k1 plus k2.
Times A. This is k prime.
So if you were to do an
experiment under these
conditions, you'd find that A
behaves, it's basically a
pseudo first order problem.
With a funny rate that contains
all the elementary
rate constants as part of it.
And when you do the same thing
for C, dC/dt, you find that
depends on A. It's k1, you plug
these steady states in
here. k1 k2 divided by
k1 plus k2 times A.
This is k prime again.
So the problem, and
it's first order.
So the problem looks like
effectively you're going from
A to C. Forget about
the intermediate.
With an effective
rate k prime.
Where k prime contains
these rates.
So this is steady state
approximation.
It's the prototypical problem.
Questions on steady state,
before we go to the next
approximation.
Alright.
So now, as promised, the next
approximation is that where
are set up the fast
equilibrium.
And you can use thermo
to help you out.
Equilibrium approximation
A goes to B.
This is a fast process.
And then k2 out of B
is a slow process.
Little arrow here, and
two big arrows here.
You put your A in your flask.
Immediately you set up
the equilibrium.
And you slowly dribble
out of that.
If you want to do it as a
function of buckets and, so
you have a big pipe connecting
two buckets that are just
offset from each other.
So there's, in this case here
B is favored over A. Because
it's a little bit lower
than this guy here.
And then there's a little
bucket, there's a little tube,
comes out of here.
So there's a little dribble
into C over time.
First thing that happens is you
set up your equilibrium.
And then you slowly extract
stuff through a little tube
into C.
So what do you expect
this to look like?
Well, you expect A to really
slowly come out.
Because the rate limiting step
is the rate from B to C. So k2
is going to be the way that
A is going to come out.
You expect it to
slowly go away.
You expect B to get created
very fast, to
some equilibrium amount.
And then also to follow
the same rate
k2, slow k2, to disappear.
And you expect C to come up.
You're basically in a first
order process to
saturation of A0.
So when you expect the dominant
rate to be k2, and
the fast dynamics to happen at
very, very early times, and
then everything to follow
first order kinetics.
So now let's do the math and
make sure that it agrees with
what we've just assumed that
it's going to look like.
So equilibrium is happening.
You can assume that at any time
after the initial very
fast process of getting
equilibrium.
So after some initial time,
the ratio of B over A is
always going to be a constant.
The dribble out of B here is not
going to be fast enough to
change that ratio.
As soon as you get a little bit
of B out here, immediately
the ratios, the amounts
rearrange to
keep the ratio constant.
So now when I look at the rate
of the reaction, the rate of
formation of C, k2 times B,
well, in terms of A, it's k2
times K equilibrium.
Times A. Which is k2 times k1
over k minus one times A. And
you can immediately see that C
is behaving, or the reaction
is behaving, like a first
order process.
With an effective rate which
contains all three rates in
this ratio here.
So it looks like A goes to C,
with some k prime where this
is k prime.
It looks like A goes to
C with an effective
rate constant k prime.
OK.
Questions?
We're going to do
some examples.
And then we're going to do chain
reactions next time.
We're one lecture behind.
Alright.
Let's do some reactions.
Some examples.
I'm going to skip the first
example, which is the example
with the chaperone,
in the notes.
And I'm going to go directly
to the gas decomposition.
The two examples are basically
very similar in their use of
the steady state
approximation.
So I'll let you read over
the first example.
So this example here is going
to give us the Lindemann
mechanism, for which Mr.
Lindemann got a Nobel Prize
many many, years ago.
Basically, it's looking
at decomposition
of a gas phase molecule.
Where you have a molecule,
A, that
breaks down into products.
And the observation before Mr.
Lindemann got around, was that
it looked like a first
order process.
It looked like A is just falling
apart on its own into
these products.
Mr. Lindemann got around and
said, well, why would A just
want to fall apart.
There's something a little
bit odd about that.
Stable molecule, why would
it want to fall apart.
And so he hypothesized
a mechanism.
And it went like this.
That A actually collides with
another molecule, which could
be a bystander.
Could be a chaperone molecule
that just happens to be there.
Or it could be another
molecule of
A. There's a collision.
There's a collision that
creates a vibrationally
excited version of A.
Of A sitting there.
It collides.
It suddenly starts to be really
vibrationally excited.
Bonds vibrate all
over the place.
Atoms wiggle.
There's the collision partner
that goes away.
So kinetic energy is transferred
from M and A to
the vibrational loads of A. In a
process which is reversible.
k1, k minus one, because this
excited A, this vibrationally
excited A, could also collide
with a molecule and cool down.
The energy in the vibrations
could be transferred back to
kinetic energy for a
reverse process.
But if you wait long enough,
or if this vibrationally
excited A, with these atoms
widely moving around, that has
more of a chance of falling
apart than this guy here.
So A star could fall apart
into products.
With a rate k2.
So he said, this is actually
an important step.
It's not that A just suddenly
falls apart.
But this has to happen.
So all the observations that
supported a first order
process, which basically only
supported one elementary
reactions, might not be right.
So let's assume his mechanism,
and let's look at what we need
to do as an approximation.
And where that leads us
in terms of trying to
experimentally confirm that this
mechanism is plausible.
Not prove it, but just to make
sure that it's consistent
with, the data's consistent
with the hypothesis.
So let's compare
our rates here.
So we have a collision.
A and M collide, and there's a
certain probability on the
collision that kinetic energy
will be transferred to
vibrational energy.
That turns out to be a
moderate probability.
So k1 is reasonably fast.
The reverse process, you have
something that's vibrationally
excited colliding
with a molecule.
There's a probability that that
excitation is going to
get turned back into
kinetic energy.
And then these two molecules
will fly
apart with high velocity.
And that tends to be much
more highly probable
then the first process.
So this is faster.
Then the excited molecule's
waiting around.
And there's a probability that
there's it's going to just
fall apart.
And that turns out to
be really slow.
So we're going to assume that
the last step is a slow step.
So what does it look like?
Well, we have the creation
is fast.
So the intermediate is fast.
But the destruction through
the reverse
process is much faster.
We have at least one step, out
of the intermediate, which is
faster than the step into
the intermediate.
That's all we care about.
It doesn't really matter that
this is slow in terms of using
the steady state
approximation.
We just want the step getting
out of the intermediate, a
backwards step in this case
here, to be faster than the
state into the intermediate.
So this allows this, this fact
that this is faster, that
allows us to use a steady
state approximation.
So now we can go ahead and
solve the problem.
So we write down all the
rates minus dA/dt.
It's k1 A. Let's start with
the rate of the action.
Let's take a product.
Let's take C. Let's say this
goes to product C here.
So dC/dt is equal to
k2 times A, that's
the rate of the reaction.
And we're going to look at
this rate of reaction.
And see how it changes.
What it looks like under
limiting conditions.
The rate of reaction.
Let's look at the
intermediate.
Because this is what we're going
to solve first, because
this is going to turn out to
be an algebraic equation.
Because we're going to apply
the steady state
approximations.
Intermediate d A star / dt is,
we can create it through the
forward process.
We destroy it through the
backwards process.
A star times M. And we destroy
it through the final process.
A star.
We apply the steady state
approximation, steady state,
steady state.
We solve for A steady state
algebraically. k1 A M over M
times k minus 1 plus k2.
And then we plug that back into
the rate of the reaction.
The rate of appearance of C.
Which is what we're measuring
experimentally.
We're looking at the products.
Measuring the appearance
of products.
So they're destruction.
This is also equal to the
destruction of A.
And so we plug this into the, we
write our rate of reaction.
Which we measure,
experimentally.
We find this is k1 times k2.
Times, we plug in for, and
here, what we do here, we
solve A in terms of
A steady state.
A is equal to something
Well, let's see, A is equal to
M k minus one plus k2 times,
well this is actually,
I have this wrong up
here, this is d A star.
So we don't need to
do this here.
The appearance of C
is, A star here.
So we plug in A steady
state here.
A star steady state, and this
is A star steady state.
The intermediate is what we're
solving a steady state for.
So this is k1 k2 A M over
M k minus one plus k2.
We just have the extra k2 that
appears when we multiply A
steady state star with
the k2 there.
And then we can look at
the limiting cases.
There are two limiting cases,
which we can tell by looking
at the denominator.
If we have one term bigger
than the other.
Only two choices here.
So the first case is where
M k minus one is
much bigger than k2.
Experimentally, what
does that mean?
It means that this in
the gas phase now.
It means that regardless of
what these rates are here,
we've managed to make the
concentration of M high enough
so that this becomes true.
There's always an M that's going
to be high enough so
that the multiplication of
these two is going to be
bigger than that.
What does that mean?
It means that the pressure
is high.
Concentration of M is high.
This is a high pressure case.
And then the other one
is M k minus one is
much less than k2.
M is very small.
Low concentration,
low pressure.
The partial pressure
of M is very low.
This could be A. M could be A,
or it could be some other
molecule that's in the mix.
And by high pressure we mean
something on the order of one
bar, let's say.
That by low pressure we mean
something around 10 to the
minus 4 bar.
So now we can go and put these
limiting cases in our equation
here. k minus one is much bigger
than k2, so we can
ignore k2 here.
And then we have something
that looks
like the M's disappear.
We have something that looks
like k1 k2 over k minus one
times A is the rate
of reaction.
First order.
Looks like it's first
order in A. This is
what people had observed.
Great.
The problem is that
they didn't know
to go to low pressure.
They were doing all
their experiments
at atmospheric pressure.
They were getting a
first order rate.
They thought they had
solved the problem.
It's just A falling
apart by itself.
Until you go to low pressure,
where now this term dominates
the denominator.
Or rather, this one dominates
And now you have something of
the form k1 A times M. This
dominates, this term
goes away.
The k2 goes away and you have
k1 times A times M left over
as the rate of the reaction.
Second order.
There are two species here.
A times M. M could be A or it
could be some chaperone.
A squared.
Second order process.
So if you're at low
pressure, you see
something at second order.
You've discovered something
about the mechanisms you
didn't expect.
And then you get
a Nobel Prize.
Alright, next time we'll
do chain reactions.